we talked about griffin cannon gooby
this is his eighth start of the year his
ninth appearance overall working with an
era of 5.56
it's a swing right through that one it
pops away and i think far enough away
where you'll have the runner advance to
second base first base obviously
occupied o2 get a chase now
he did get a chase
95 miles an hour below the knees
here's the pitch he swings and misses a
slider and griffin canning after giving
up that lead off single comes back and
strikes out three in a row and the
inning is over this will be the tenth
start of the season for dane dunning we
talked about him in the open he's been
really good and probably coming off his
best start of the year he had his
highest game score of any game so far
halo's getting ready to go to work
offensively justin upton at the top of
the order
there he is again the lead off man so
comfortable in that spot just enough to
get out of here
justin upton going uptown funk again
back-to-back days lead off home runs one
the left one the right against the
rangers
loving that lead all spot he goes ricky
henderson who
i was thinking the same name gooby
a couple of pretty good base runners out
there on the diamond now it's a shift
defensively for jose rojas here's the
pitch and this is chopped on the right
side that's going to skip on through
into right center field a run will score
rojas delivers
two out rbi hit that brings in walsh
two-nothing angels
well nick solak the second baseman is
playing him keep the shortstop kinder
philetha home on the left side of the
infield creating a lot of space up the
middle rojas uses this just rolls the
ball right back up the middle and just
where solac was positioned he just could
not get to it walsh reached on a walk
laguerra single and rojas cashes in here
is taylor ward
ward high fly ball deep lefty and taylor
did it
that's a party at the big a why aren't
you here
and the best playing baseball the
three-run home run taylor ward style
fourth home uh 12 rbis
get that chance to play every day even
with two strikes on him in the back
fouled off a couple tough ones got a
mistake and he hammers it out
another breaker ball that drifts on the
inner half
slider
and he crushes it a long long way okay
so now show a otani
3-2
swing in a miss strike three throw to
second a good one got him for the double
play
a strike him out throw him out twin
killing executed perfectly by heim and
the inning is done
you'd love to see it and perhaps maybe a
momentum builder here for dane dunning
does a great job of coming back and
finishing off shohei ohtani and then a
really strong throw there from jonah
heim good tag from isaiah kinder
philippa kinder fulfa up the middle but
still on the left side outfield also
plays into pull as this pitch is pulled
out into right field coming on as joey
gallo he dives and he makes the catch
joey gallo coming in quickly to make a
diving catch on that sinking liner to
get rojas for the final out he is
challenging a rangers record he's tied
it
with 10 home runs this month that is the
most by any ranger rookie in a month
dave hostetler did it back in 1982.
how many strikes will he see going
forward teams are going to stop throwing
pitches in the zone to him
that one's up but he doesn't care
hammers that one out to left field and
gone
that was a bolt right over the fence
number 16
for el bumby
and the rangers are on the board
and a new rookie record for the most
home runs in a month as we've just shown
you 11 now here in the month of may for
garcia and perhaps the first of that
back to back to back that we want to see
so badly but this is impressive
dole's garcia goes up above the strike
zone again
and you mentioned well okay they're not
going to throw them strikes i don't know
if it matters
as he goes outside the strike zone and
just absolutely annihilates this
baseball
he's a very aggressive man over there
speaking of aggressive oh my goodness
now that is a slap shot
and that is how the inning will end they
got the lead off homer and that was it
we're headed to the bottom of the port
hit hard to a backhand on a knee walsh
little flip this is the beginning as you
told us for canning one out yeah huge
all of a sudden dunning's putting up
some zeros got through that anyway no
damage
elevates this one
well that's a long run there for
rojas
that is a really really good play in
front of the gold glove center fielder
oh for seven in the two-game series
right now trying to get things going
with his back
here's the pitch he rips that one into
left field and that's gonna bounce all
the way out to the short wall ohtani's
going into third he is going to be waved
home ball was fumbled around a little
bit by calhoun brandon's at second has
an rbi double the angels add on it's now
6-1
out of the university of kansas terry
here's the pitch uh fly ball hit into
shallow left field coming in and unable
to get to it in time is calhoun it drops
in front of him coming in and scoring on
that rbi single will be rendone
lagaris another two hit game for him
and the angels now lead it seven to one
breaks his bat finds a hole it plays one
here comes rojas to the plate
standing up he's in there ward will
hustle on in head first slide into
second
oh the angels are having all kinds of
fun they lead it 9-1 and we got a
hitting for the cycle watch down for
kevin ward it's a triple away
a home run a double now a single
it was not unusual back then
in the pitch that swung on and that's
hit well by nate lowe
straight away right way back there and
it is history he clears the 16 foot high
wall
two-run homer for nate lowe is eighth of
the year his 29th and 30th rbis
and the angels lead is cut to 9-3 in the
top of the sixth
the rangers have authored a number of
come from behind wins this year last at
bat victories and the like
gallow hammers apple
high in the air deep out to right and
gone
towering
gallow home run
third homer the afternoon for the
rangers
and it gets a little more interesting
here in the eighth
nine to five two men out there holt's
never faced myers before big 3-2 pitch
and that ball's hit well
down toward the right field corner and
that one will bounce up in the seats for
an automatic double
davis scores kinder fellow will have to
stop at third but the tying run will
come to the plate in the eighth inning
it's nine to six
so it's 9-6
and martin pinch hitting here is the
tying run
here comes the pitch
and that is swung on and lying down the
right field line hooking in the corner
it is in there for extra bases
one run is home two runs are home and in
its second with a double is willie
calhoun
the angels lead has been cut to nine
eight
and here comes nick solak with two outs
in the eighth it's also bear down time
as the anxiety is cranked up in that
third base dug out rice eli glacias
comes on to go to work in this nine
eight game
solac bouncing ball back behind the bag
in time for the out
[Applause]
so close good play by robots
got him went back to him a good one
that's a good adjustment
this is a great feedback
what a great sequence by
what's up
not glaciers to give this one away the
angels once up 9-1 are victorious by a
score of nine to eight the halos have
won three in a row and congrats to joe
matt in his 1300th career victory as a
manager